Robbie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Chelsea Andrew are two people you know
what you want in life and you know what
you want when it comes to dating to life
to everything so it's time to find out
about your biggest deal breakers and
again we call Red Flag yellow flag green
flag
so here's how it works I'm going to give
up some scenarios if you're cool with it
you're gonna bring out your green flag
all right if it's a little neutral you
don't care so much yellow flag and if
it's a hard pass red flag got it this is
so fun okay first up so let's say you're
madly in love with somebody but it turns
out that he is or they are allergic to
dogs
red flag green flag or red flag
I can work with that you can't maybe you
can have dogs but I don't have to be
full time with someone
that's a built-in barrier you're right
stay at your house this could be a
part-time commitment yeah you I don't
think you should turn down uh the right
person for allergies right yeah yeah get
a Zyrtec and go nuts or just put you
know put the dogs away hang out and then
go back to your life yeah yeah exactly
or meet in a yeah whatever that's not a
big deal are you supposed to hold the
flag like that
so allergic to dogs not a deal breaker
what about this one I love this word he
or they are looking to be in a throuple
I don't like that no thrupples for
Chelsea Handler no I don't mind being
the third party but I don't want that
any to be any other position
primary party having a throuple but I
wouldn't mind be the person coming in
and out
oh my God relationships are hard enough
I I guess I I just because I don't know
who know who I'm dealing with I'm gonna
do that but you know I don't know
there's I I guess this it sounds
exhausting you have to fake it twice all
right what about this uh it's below 70
degrees out and they show up to a date
wearing flip-flops okay
that's in your special Chelsea's I knew
that you couldn't do this oh I hate
flip-flops and I think they should be
illegal
what is it about them they're just for
men it's not for them it's for girls and
gay men who take care of your feet and
get pedicures and they you can't just
whip your feet out no that's not
acceptable to me anymore
[Applause]
I personally love a guy who wears like
slides with socks my ex-boyfriend Luke
used to wear like socks and his Adidas
and I was so turned on
I love that I thought he was so cool I
used to wear like a visor I was like who
makes visors look he sounds like he's in
a 70s porno
all right what if you were dating
somebody and it turned out they were a
total prude oh that's a red flag for me
I need somebody who can have a good time
yeah who can party yeah party all of it
they're not gonna like me no I'll just
do the work for them no yeah I don't
want to waste your time and you're not
gonna waste mine okay this one's
interesting what if they tell you on the
first date that they have kids but they
didn't include that in their online
profile okay I'm not mad at that okay
because okay as long as you get it as
you know face to face the first face to
face if they tell you the truth then
that's what the most important thing is
some people might say their dating app
is not the place for their kids or to
discuss it or show them and I know
because I'm one of them oh see I love
that this is not a forum about my kids
yeah we're not up for the selling point
or any of it I was talking to this guy
and we were texting and then like the
third text in he said something like oh
I'm just putting the kids to bed with my
wife and I reread it and I went what and
then I went back and he said oh just
here for friends married with children
and I thought who's on a dating app to
meet friends like if you don't have
friends and you don't know how to figure
out like red flag red flag I was like
buddy I'm not talking to you to become
friends okay
I know that was so weird to me and then
I was looking and I guess that's a
category where you can be like I'm just
here to meet people and you're like now
I see that a lot not the married thing
but the here just for friends and then
I'm like okay well we're all shopping
here and if the cart is full why are you
here yeah it's like going to the grocery
store for a library book darling you're
at the wrong spot right on that same
dating app this guy wrote he was like I
grew up above a cobbler shop so the
scent of leather just is so nostalgic
and every time I smell it I brought back
to my childhood and I was like all right
well you know jokingly I'm like well if
I smell any leather today I'll let you
know
and um I said but you know what an
interesting story and he goes oh I made
it up
and I just went
or block why would someone make up a
elaborate story about their childhood
that wasn't true
really that hard out there it's not
we're talking about an app that's like
harder to get on but because if I look
at my sister's apps that she's on which
are like more public apps public facing
apps you know Bumble or whatever the
latest ones are every man is holding a
fish yeah and it's like I don't
understand stand what that Allure is
like they're roping Us in with sea bass
yeah I think it's a little hot I don't
know I'm into outdoorsy
I'm not interested in efficient and
somebody who's catching big fish
all right what about this yeah you
you're looking at somebody's online
profile and this is their picture
back here Chelsea
that's the red flag for me
I I think I'm more concerned he's too
young for me you're you're looking at
the man look at the cats all right
looking at the cats that's the only
thing that's keeping this flag up is the
cats really the yellow flag is for the
cats not the man I love animals so I
think I'm saying but the cats are a
possibility probably not him I I just
think he also just looks way too young
for me so that's that's what's stopping
me there he looks like he's busy with
his kitties all right let's say um on
their profile it says this word is
interesting that they are an
entrepreneur oh yeah that's stupid
why why is such a red flag Andre is that
a bad thing to be so it's just so it's
it just sounds like such a crock like
what are you talking about get specific
you know what business are you in if
you're an entrepreneur like you know
Renewables what entrepreneurial business
are you in you want a specific Drew
it's so irritatingly vague I won't play
I just just please be upfront about who
you are we're all we've all got a mining
cap on in these dating apps just tell me
who you are let's be upfront about it
yeah I I've never I'm not like out there
dating Rich powerful you know uh
fabulous people that's not like my thing
so I'm not judging you for your job I
just want you to be honest and
transparent yeah that seems like a word
that you use when you don't have a job
and you're just trying to lie like
unemployed oh I'm an entrepreneur I'd
rather someone say I'm between jobs
right now yes exactly honestly always
yes just please be transparent okay well
this one's more interesting okay because
it has to do with etiquette so these are
his table manners
what do I do if I don't want this piece
of food in my mouth oh what if I just
did this yeah
[Applause]
I will never forget that
if it were on a first date and someone
just spit out there
but I like that she covered her mouth
while she was doing it well you just go
okay what about this so you go on a
couple dates uh with somebody cute cute
and then all of a sudden they want to
sext you like get dirty in the inbox or
well you know what I mean stop it you
know just like text each other but after
you've already had sex with them no you
just gone a couple days oh it's cute how
fun and then all of a sudden it's like
what are you wearing uh yeah I don't
like that until you've had some
penetration
like that is not foreplay to you no
I find that creepy and it's overstepping
Chelsea whether it's Daytime Nighttime
morning noon or night
um we need you yeah we do we need you on
TV
[Applause]
right now and it is just
from as are you I love you I cannot wait
February 6 on The Daily Show
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]